voilà ce n'est jamais anodin de tuer les
animaux on a entendu la souffrance que
cela provoque chez ces femmes et ces
hommes ils sont confrontés à la vie à la
mort à la violence des questions
vertigineuses face auquel ils se sentent
seuls pourquoi est-ce un tabou dans
notre société
est il possible d'améliorer les
conditions de travail les conditions
d'abattage la réglementation est mis en
cause on l'a entendu et elle inadaptée
on va poser toutes ses questions à
présent après ce film les damnés
d'anne-sophie reinhardt et pour
approfondir j'accueille franck montaugé
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur ps du
gers avec nous également eric baratay
bonjourbonjour historiens ou des
spécialistes des relations entre les
hommes et les animaux et nous sommes
avec ghislain pajot bonjour vous êtes
éleveurs éleveurs de bovins en
loire-atlantique président de
l'association albi qui signifie abattage
des animaux sur leurs lieux de vie et
membre d'un collectif le collectif quand
l'abattoir vient à la ferme vous allez
nous en dire plus dans quelques instants
vrai tout d'abord qu'on revienne sur ses
paroles très fortes que nous venons
d'entendre assez rare finalement on
entend assez peut l'aider des paroles
d'ouvriers dans ces abattoirs
franck montaugé à quoi est-ce que c'est
lié d'abord la force et puis la rareté
de ces paroles c'est un c'est un tabou
en france les abattoirs sont des univers
très particulier
on le voit à travers les témoignages à
la façon dont les opérateurs
vive vivent cet univers professionnel
beaucoup d'interrogations sur le sens de
la vie sur le sens du travail
je pense pas qu'ils voient là il faut
pas il faut pas cliver trop cliver sur
ces questions là je pense qu'on a on a
tous notre part de responsabilité on
j'adore la vienne donc voilà par exemple
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut
vraiment un débat pour faire pour faire
progresser le sujet il ya énormément de
pistes de progrès possible on va pouvoir
débattre peut-être un mot ghislain pajot
vous qui êtes éleveurs les paroles qu'on
vient d'entendre
elles vous ont particulièrement touché
qui ne veut pas être touché par tout
c'est ce puissant discours qui est qui
est vécu par ces personnes donc c'est
vraiment le système poussé à son extrême
enfin on espère ce que c'est l'extrême
on va pouvoir améliorer les choses et on
voit c'est un des absurdités qui
détruisent les hommes et les femmes est
forcément enfin pour ma part je souffre
avec eux eric baratay on disait la mort
est mise à distance
on al impression qu effectivement ce
qu'on entend on n'entend quasiment
jamais
c'est ça a toujours été comme ça dans la
société française oui non en fait les
abattoirs ont été constitués pour ça
pour mettre les choses dans un coin en
silence que ça ne se fasse sans qu'on ne
voit rien parce que au milieu du xixème
siècle on tue dans les rues
1 les boucheries ça se fait en pleine
rue le sang et dans les les caniveaux
les tripes et caetera et on construit
des abattoirs et on enferme les
abattoirs justement parce que les
plaintes montrent de plus en plus contre
ces tueries ces cris d'animaux que les
rangs on est entre 1800 1850 et les gens
ne supportent plus et on a créé les
abattoirs pour ça les abattoirs seront
tous souvent été créé à la périphérie
entouré de murs et pour tuer finalement
en cachette on en a fait un tabou et ça
a très bien marché tout le long du xxème
siècle
et la grande nouveauté finalement c'est
qu'on voit maintenant que le système ne
fonctionne plus
le tabou ne marche plus parce que
justement il ya des ouvriers qui parle
il ya des associations qui font des
reportages etc et le parti pris du film
c'est intéressant ça ne pas montrer des
images chocs contrairement à celle qu'on
voit dans les réseaux de réseaux sociaux
vous le comprenez ça franck montaugé
j'ai fait beaucoup de visites
d'abattoirs donc je sais c'est un
univers que je connais on n'en sort
jamais voilà elle même s'interroge
vraiment pour pro profondément mais
voilà je j'ai je comprends qu'il n'y ait
passé ses images et parce que par
ailleurs on sait qu'elles sont
accessibles notamment sur internet voilà
donc je pense que c'est un traitement
pas décalé mais complémentaires ce qu'on
peut voir par ailleurs
je n'ai qu'une qu'un regret que je me
permet d'exprimer c'est que les les
chefs d'entreprise les responsables
d'abattoirs ne n'ai pas eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer
ce n'est peut-être pas plus facile pour
eux certains égards à certains égards un
que ça ne l'est pour les opérateurs même
si je ne mets pas les choses sur le même
plan mais voilà il y aurait t il aurait
été intéressant qu'on puisse les
entendre on parle encore un tout petit
peu du film eric baratin commentaires
sur le titre les damnés on est dans le
registre religieux et s'est pas
complètement anodin quand on parle de
tuer des animaux un oui tout à fait il
ya une histoire de sacrés effectivement
on le trouve dans la bible le dans la
genèse l'homme adam et eve sont
végétariens il faut attendre le péché
originel pour que dieu donne le droit de
tuer les bêtes un donc ce n'est pas ça
n'est pas une sans hélas les damnés
c'est les hommes mais c'est aussi les
damnés et c'est aussi les animaux dans
cette affaire là il dirait il ya presque
une histoire de compagnonnage de misère
entre le travail très dur de ces hommes
et puis ce qui arrive aux animaux mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ce sort
des animaux
on l'avait mis de côté au 20e siècle on
s'est beaucoup intéressée au xxème
siècle aux animaux de compagnie aux
chiens ou chats et cetera puis aux
animaux sauvages comment les protéger et
ce qui arrive
maintenant sur le débat c'est justement
les animaux de ferme les animaux
d'abattoir qu'on avait complètement
oublié au 20e siècle
parce que on a vu tout un discours sur
il faut manger de la viande on s'est mis
dans la surconsommation de viande et
pour en échange et bien on a fait à bout
sur la manière dont on tuer les animaux
voudrait qu'on écoute l'un des
personnages de ce film qu'il ya des mots
très forts et notamment ceux de
l'écrivain joseph pontus qui est décédé
depuis et qui attire et qui avait tiré
un très beau livre de cette expérience
d'ouvriers et notamment d'ouvriers en
abattoir propose de revoir cet extrait
et et ghislain pajot on aura une
question pour vous après l'abattoir tu
es dans le truc le plus symbolique le
plus violent de ce qu'est l'accord
alimentaire aujourd'hui je pense depuis
des années
c'est à dire que tu vois la mort et tu
sens la mort
[Musique]
il faut se dire effectivement je suis un
élément participatif constitutif
de l'industrie de la mort c'est pas
anodin c'est qu'on fabrique pas des
faits soit on tue des buts
et on tue des bêtes de manière
industrielle
béthouart où je me sais c'était 700
lâché 3500 caution par jour 700 la chef
est un cheptel
ghislain pajot une réaction sur ce mot
qu'on entend à deux reprises dans cet
extrait dans la bouche de joseph spontus
c'est une industrie en tue de manière
industrielle est ce qu'une part du
problème n'est pas là complètement la
l'industrialisation a entraîné une prise
de distance énorme avec le sujet et nous
justement ce qu'on souhaite c'est
replace l'humain et l'animal au coeur de
notre projet à hallwil donc la vis torx
associations d'éleveurs aider le feu
ceux de loire-atlantique et de vendée
qui oeuvre à la mise en place d'un mode
d'abattoirs d'abattage et innovant
l'abattage à la ferme c'est à dire que
sur tout moment là dira présence de la
batteur dira présence de l'éleveur et de
l'animal sur son lieu de vie et ça nous
permet donc de voir dans le film c'est
beaucoup de solitude là vous dites il ya
au moins trois protagonistes qui sont là
au moment de l'abattage dans votre
système
voilà c'est ne pas faire porter la
responsabilité de la mise à mort on l'a
fait pour la bientraitance animal pour
notre tranquillité à nous en tant
qu'éleveur est sûre que tout se passe
bien
et au fur et à mesure qu'on a avancé le
projet le les opérateurs d'abattre quoi
se sont sentis grandi le fait de pouvoir
aller dans les fermes voir où étaient
élevés les animaux de savoir que nous on
allait accompagner l'animal dans ce
moment là on s'est vraiment rendu compte
qu'on partage est vraiment le même sens
et que l'animal du coup se trouvait on
va dire en sécurité ce qu'est ce qui est
important c'est qu'on se rend bien
compte qu'il ya un lien entre la
souffrance de ces personnes qu'on a
entendues dans le documentaire et la
maltraitance des animaux là la
souffrance psychique
l'ige alors je me tourne vers vous
franck montaugé législateur il ya des
choses à faire on sait qu'il ya
notamment depuis avril 2019 une
disposition de la loi agriculture et
alimentation qui permet cette cette
expérimentation de l'abattage mobile est
ce que ça c'est l'une des solutions
qu'il faudrait encourager et est-ce
qu'il y en a d'autres moi je pense que
tout toutes les formes doivent être
encouragés pour pour autant qu'elles
qu'elles permettent de respecter
l'animal voire d'améliorer le bien être
de l'animal
donc je pense que c'est la condition la
condition de base à respecter par
rapport aux différents type d'abattage
possible je suis de ceux qui pensent qu
effectivement il faut permettre
l'abattage de la ferme
il faut aussi permettre que des
abattoirs de taille moyenne ou de
tailles petite puisse continuer à
fonctionner j'ai dans mon département
dans le gers eux contribuer au sauvetage
d'un abattoir qui fait 8000 tonnes par
an qui sert surtout à tous les
producteurs locaux
donc ça permet de limiter les transports
donc ça a un impact évidemment sur le
bien-être animal et sur la qualité de la
viande
la durée de son sport a un impact sur la
qualité la wii le stress le stress de
valeur jeu je parle je parle sous le
contrôle d'un professionnel mais je le
stress évidemment un lien avec la
qualité la qualité de la vienne et je
peux vous dire aussi que je me suis
battu c'est assez récemment pour que les
normes européennes permettent l'abattage
des canards aussi à la ferme parce qu'on
n'était pas loin de ne plus pouvoir le
faire et il y avait aussi un enjeu un
jeu par rapport à ce type ce type
d'abattage à la ferme qui doit être qui
doit être possible nous indiquions ça va
grâce à des dons moi je n'oppose pas les
solutions les unes aux autres je pense
qu'il faut créer les conditions les
possibilités pour que les différentes
les différents mandats d'abattage puisse
se la prospère et à partir du moment où
le bien-être animal est respectée voire
améliorées eric baratay question pour
vous parce que
on vous le disait tout à l'heure il ya
une prise de conscience depuis quelques
temps ghislain page onuzi au tout début
de l'émission
on est à l'extrême d'un système on voit
bien que c'est une absurdité
à quel moment il ya une prise de
conscience dans la société française
l'avant l'histoire récente
on se dote de 10 15 ans à peu près où il
ya eu un grand film en 1949 sur les
abattoirs de la villette qui montrait
comment ça se passait il ya eu aucun
écho dans la société parce que la
société était parti dans mon était dans
les partis dans des trente glorieuses et
la consommation de viande était un
symbole de richesse et c'est ça qu'il
faut remettre en cause et par exemple si
le système de l'abattage à la ferme moi
je suis tout à fait favorable à une
condition je pense que les éleveurs qui
promeut ça ils devront être très
attentif parce que on a inventé les
abattoirs pour éviter tous les abus des
l'abattage à la ferme
lesquels eh ben il gène ikke mauvais
abattage et cetera dans de très
mauvaises conditions et donc les gens
qui prônent moussa doivent être
extrêmement vigilant pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d au bout d'un compte des requins
qui se met là dedans et qui détruisent
le système alors là ghislain pajot c'est
intéressant comment est ce que vous
répondez à cette voie là non pas une
critique mais cette question comment est
ce que l on garantit au consommateur que
l'abattage à la ferme d'un point de
visionique notamment ne posent aucune de
aucun problème monsieur bah rater
complètement raison il faut qu'on soit
extrêmement vigilants à la qualité du
travail qui est fait et ça toute façon
c'est un c'est un préalable à notre
travail
donc ça fait quatre ans maintenant qu'on
est en train de déployer toute une
batterie de protocole pour que justement
techniquement ce soit irréprochable pour
que la qualité de la viande soit
exceptionnel derrière et pour rejoindre
monsieur montaugé
vous avez bien fait parce que dans le
projet au tout départ comme il ya quatre
ans quand on réfléchit à l'abattage à la
ferme on imagine mai l'abattoir sur
roues donc à voir
un camion mobile l'abattage et on avait
la chance à l'époque d'avoir un abattoir
locales dans ses tirs on va pas rentrer
en concurrence
on a travaillé sur un jet qui met en
cohérence un abattoir local et un réseau
de caisses seront qui se déplace dans
les fermes en lien avec cet abattoir là
alors voila si franck montaugé vous
vouliez je voulais faire une remarque
que nos remarques générales
on ne peut pas traiter de cette question
dans sa dans sa diversité dans les
diversité de formes qu'on a qu'on a
évoqué en faisant abstraction des
données économiques et j'ai je regrette
d'avoir à dire le mot des données de
rentabilité économique voilà il faut des
modèles économiques équilibrées et il
faut que voilà les modèles économiques
soit adaptée au marché aux marchés qui
sont servis voilà est à cet égard c'est
un problème agricole nationale on sait
la part que représente aujourd'hui dans
le budget des ménages la nourriture et
la vienne en particulier c'est qu'il y
en a de moins en moins de moyens qui
sont consacrés à ce type à ce type de
nourriture
donc il faut il faut il faut trouver des
modèles économiques et donc des systèmes
économiques d'abattage notamment mais
d'élevage aussi voilà un rapport
économie ouverte mondialisée est ce que
est ce que le petit abattoir peut
résister face aux industries et je pense
je pense qu'il ya une action d'éducation
à faire aussi du côté du consommateur
c'est à dire de lui apprendre à manger
moins de viande mais de viande de
meilleure qualité donc plus cher pour
que le système soit rentable à ces
méthodes et les moyens qu'ils aient les
moyens
oui mais au lieu d'en manger tous les
jours qu'ils en mangent que deux fois
par semaine
ce n'est pas une obligation de manger
tous les jours comme mon contrat mort ce
qu'on nous l'a dit au 20e siècle
je pense que l'une des solutions elle
est là 1 c'est à dire de baisser le
nombre d'animaux abattus
et puis l'autre solution c'est qu'il
faut revoir les modes d'abattage nous
vivons
sur un mode d'abattage qui date des
années 60 qui soler d'abattage il
n'entend est question on parle beaucoup
d'une notamment d'anciens on parle du
matador tout ça c'est exactement ça n'a
pas bougé depuis 60 ans et l'a dit mais
c'est très mal
c'est très mal appliquée il faut innover
il faudrait innover pour l'aca oui là je
veux dire ça c'est la dimension
technologique et investissements du
sujet moi je pense qu'on doit progresser
sur ce sujet notamment dans les
abattoirs industriels
s'il y en aura voilà ça va encore durer
un peu je ne suis que je suis convaincu
c'est par ailleurs nécessaire pour
certaines marché donc il faut qu'on
progresse sur les investissements moi je
veux je peux pas croire qu'on ne soit
pas à mesure d'abattre de manière plus
correct qu'on ne le fait aujourd'hui on
connaît les témoignages ne le disent
notamment dans ce documentaire leur
garde à tous d'accord pourtant progresse
pas s'essayer à quoi c'est parce que le
problème il ya 1 point de rentabilité de
modèles ayant un problème de moyens qui
se posent sur certaines viennent ce
qu'on appelle le minerai vous savez ce
qui fait les steaks hachés etc qui est
quand même une part importante du marché
du marché de la vienne aujourd'hui même
si c'est pas tout le marché les taux de
rentabilité au kilo s'évalue à quelques
centimes à quelques centimes donc il ya
une dimension aussi économiques
kiki et qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut
pas évacuer vous dites que la notamment
pour ses quelques jeux proposent ce type
devient de l'art peut pas faire
autrement qu'avec la matière
industrielle
je dis je c'est le cas aujourd'hui ça me
paraît ça me paraît hasardeux de 2,2 de
vous répondre par oui ou par donc je
pense que c'est un système qu'il faut
prendre en compte qu'il faut améliorer
voilà moi je suis convaincu de ça et je
vais même plus loin je pense que les
industriels eux mêmes de
l'agroalimentaire en concernés ont
intérêt à démontrer que les choses
progressent
qu'elles se font mieux ils ont démontré
votre chiffre d'affaires le consommateur
gelé les relations
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
vous dites évidemment le système est
très très sûr un rasoir et bien sûr
parce que on produit de la viande de
mauvaise qualité quand on tue mal vous
l'avez dit on transporte l'animal craie
des toxines
on le tue mal il crée des toxines on
crée de la viande de mauvaise qualité
j'étais en chine en inde en 2018 en
chine ils sont en train de prendre le
virage et à 100° j'ai vu des des
élevages libre de cochons sur des
centaines d'hectares où on leur crée des
des porcheries creuser dans les craies
donc l'animal est totalement libre donc
ils sont en train complet ils sont en
avance en chine en avant en termes de
bien-être animal havas est ce qu il faut
bien voir c'est que les efforts des
éleveurs tous les efforts denver des
éleveurs pour faire de la qualité seront
battus en brèche tant qu'on ne résoudra
pas le problème de l'abattage j'ai une
question pour vous qui n'a pas joué
rapidement parce qu'on approche de la
fin de l'émission mais par rapport à une
expression qui vient d'être employée par
eric baratte et tuer tuer mieux et puis
on tue mal est il possible de pardonnez
moi l'expression bien tu es quand on
parle des animaux des animaux d'élevage
ça interpelle le sens déjà de la vie de
l'animal
c'est à dire que si s'il a passé sa vie
enfermé entre quatre murs c'est clair
que c'est encore plus compliqué de
donner un sens à sa mort le nom un texte
qu'on aime beaucoup et comporte manger
au quotidien implique la présence
d'animaux d'élevage fumier pour
fertiliser les cultures de légumes
prairie pour filtrer l'eau de pluie et
offrir une biodiversité favorable
notamment aux abeilles miel et
pollinisation des vergers paysage pour
nous nourrir de beauté admettons enfin
que ce cycle de vie est marquée par la
mort de l'animal osons lui offrir une
solution d'abattage à la hauteur du donc
il nous fait c'est quand on est en sucre
ainsi que l'effective mans et qui a une
logique qui est loin d'ailleurs des
parfois de la manière un peu
caricaturale dans ton dont on peut poser
le débat vous vouliez ajouter quelque
chose près à venir un projet à votre
question via quelques instants par
opposition aux propositions d'objets
volés la question évoquée la question de
la technologie
je voudrais revenir sur les salariés des
abattoirs qui est qui témoigne dans ce
documentaire
moi je pense qu'il faut les accompagner
les suivre psychologiquement de manière
permanente et je crois que ça c'est
quelque chose d'absolument fondamentale
je pense qu'il faudrait envisager des
parcours de carrière dans le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire un qu'ils ne restent
pas 30 ans comme on l'a vu le moment
comment comme on l'a vu et je pense
qu'il faut aussi peut-être reconnaître
les traumatismes de la pénibilité
exceptionnelle de 2,7 de ce type de
travail donc au plan physique au plan
psychologique et je pense qu'il faut
aussi que les contrôles puissent exercer
il ya des textes ils peuvent être
améliorés mais déjà faisant respecter
les textes existants donc donnant les
moyens aux services de contrôle de
l'état
donc ça c'est une affaire
gouvernementale de faire les contrôles
les comptes comme il le faut voilà et
d'en rendre compte et je suis sûr que
les consommateurs mieux informés ils
seront sensibles compris dans leurs
choix
voilà et s'il vous plaît arrêtez je suis
un peu bavard prenons garde de ne pas
arriver à une situation où il n'y aurait
plus d'élevage en france on est on est
quand même sur cette trajectoire
moi je suis un département de
polyculture-élevage le cheptel diminue
je peux vous dire c'est une catastrophe
voilà donc il faut aussi penser aux
éleveurs les rémunère les rémunérer
correctement tout dernier mot eric
baratay je termine par vous on voit bien
que derrière tout ça il ya effectivement
des questions culturelles et notamment
changements de modes d'alimentation tout
à fait moi je le suis quand même frappé
par le développement du végétarisme
depuis une quinzaine d'années à eux je
l'attendais mais à cette allure-là pas
ce point là et je pense que l'élevage
français ne s'en sortira qu'en
n'abandonnant la productivité au profit
de la qualité
merci beaucoup à tous les trois nous
avoir éclairé sur ce débat qui est
absolument passionnant
je renvoie au livre de joseph pontus
qu'on a vu donc dans le lent le
documentaire
à la ligne c'est un roman qui est tiré
de son expérience en usine dans les
abattoirs et les conserveries c'est
paris c'est paru aux éditions de la
table ronde
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure les animaux
de compagnie eric baratay c'est l'un de
vos domaines d'expertisé culture féline
c'est un livre sur l'histoire des chats
essai paru ça vient de paraître aux
éditions du seuil
merci à chacun de nous avoir suivi et à
très bientôt sur public sénat merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]